okay we'll open the work session uh
anybody watching the work session for
public employees Labor Relations Board
has had to be rescheduled
to March 8th at 11 A.M so what we're
going to do today is just start going
through House Bill 2 maybe we can tick
off a few little things and plba has
presented us with a breakdown of all
House Bill 2 Division One sections
and uh
Melissa and Mr Hoffman if is anything
that you think we should hit right off
the bat or do we should just start with
the first one number one the department
of Information Technology
divisions established
makes sense to start at the top and work
through
example number one I think we heard from
commissioner Goulet that that is
a change
to make the statute align with the way
they do things now
no problem no no problem with this one
anybody so we can check off number one
number two is a continuation of the
ability for
doat to fill unfunded positions
so they use the Appropriations that are
are given to them
and they have that flexibility as long
as they don't exceed those
Appropriations
I representative everybody okay with
that as well Dan well I have a question
which is I mean if if some of their
money like it was given to them by dot
or something can they go fill a position
for safety you know what I mean is it
this seems a little weird yeah
they would have had the
Authority with this to make the
appropriate accounting adjustments so
they're not charging
transportation for a safety position
okay
so they have this because to me this
makes it look like they can just take
all their salary make one big blob and
and hire
whoever they want with it no
no all of their budget is other funds
right so everything they do is paid for
by other agencies to their shared costs
they distribute across the whole state
event costs are specific to that agency
and they charge that Agency for those
costs
you know representative McGuire actually
so number two is
checked off and now go to 12.
that was the employee incentive program
I think we discussed right Mr Hoffman
yes the
liquor commissioner um
described that when he was in with the
division
in relation to their struggle to find
people
given the salaries they can offer this
would help them
representative Hewitt do you have a
house bill too or I
my house bill too is oh oh okay well
there's another you can get there's one
in Janet's uh okay
it might might come up with some good
Solutions yeah
so we okay with 12. yeah for sure so
what are the dollar amounts associated
with each one of these things
yeah liquor when they gave us their
presentation there was a dollar amount
again it's their funds no General funds
but yeah
so it's in other words it'd be other
funds
that would be a good idea
I think most of these divisions need to
set up programs
Mike do you have a dollar amount by
chance or
Melissa's pulling up their presentation
right now that was the one happens so
oh no apology necessary so
okay
we get whatever they don't spend you
know I think it was about so the more
they spend the less we get yeah
yeah well definitely it's important
might be included because I think they
made the argument representative Griffin
when they were here that if they didn't
do this they couldn't keep some of their
liquor stores open or fully staffed and
I think representative Hewitt just
picked up
thanks Janet
what they said was it was a team
approach and as opposed to increasing
salaries one of the things they thought
of was using more this incentivization
so we okay with 12 Jerry
yeah I'm fine
so I would suggest on 13 and 14 that we
wait because Corrections is coming in
tomorrow
it was my thought that when these folks
come in to see us as we've done uh in
the past those of you have been here
like representative Griffin is when the
Departments present their budget they
talk speak to the house bill 2 impacts
that have been listed so everybody okay
with waiting on the 13 and 14.
and 15. and 15 and 16. yeah 15 and 16.
and then we go to 17.
yes yeah Des is coming in to see us
and that's uh 18.
as well I'm looking at my
a lot it's a lot
yeah I went through and highlighted
everything here let's see 18
and 19 is the Department of Justice
I believe these Environmental Services
sections go up into the second page
to uh
section 39 on page 16.
in
I did speak with Susan Carlson of
Environmental Services and they're going
to be prepared to talk about
the house bill two sections for their
Department
all right
so just we're skipping over 19 again
that was the Department of Justice
which will be coming in
it looks very minor
you want to get rid of 19 representative
yeah McGuire it's adding five words or
at the top of page nine it's on yeah
page nine
qualified applicants to service hearing
officers that I mean it seems pretty
I think it's all part of the GPS
well 19 starts
what's the RSA 210
Melissa Mr Hoffman 29 oh you said 21
yeah 21-0 the 21s are all the statutes
that govern the various departments
um
I mean I I can answer it in a way so at
DES there's the waste management Council
there's the water Council there's the
air Council and what this is saying is
that the Attorney General already has
some appointment appointment power to
those councils and I think it's
expanding it to include clerical and
support Personnel yeah I think
that's what all that is about
why not
so it's all part of the same
lesson all right representative evils
suggesting we bless it another
representative McGuire say why not yeah
sure yeah I see agreement there yeah but
I jump on that while we can so 19 we're
all set with Mr Hoffman Melissa
all right so now there's a bunch of
Environmental
and Mike you said that they're prepared
to speak to these when they come in yes
so we're already I'm up to page 15.
16.
it's
it's office of regulatory review
reduction in government
yeah Melissa Mr Hoffman can you help us
with uh
regulatory review reduction government
efficiency
that is a a new small agency
um
kind of a
I guess a watchdog kind of agency that
keeps an eye on administrative rules on
behalf of
interested parties been businesses and
citizens
looks like it's part of the Bea
I'm just looking at page 18 my number
one section 41.
and the appropriation
looks like it's 1.5 million
two years is that right
see page 18 number four you know
appropriation office of regulatory
review ah yes the sum of 750
twice twice so it's 1.5 million
all right so maybe we should hold on to
this in case we need to find it yes we
need to find a million and a half
just eliminated
Melissa also pointed out on that it may
need an amendment
because RSA 12p is the Department of
energy oh it's a small Point she she has
that noted
we haven't heard any testimony or
anything of it no
Melissa is this on the big list of House
Bill 2 appropriation
yeah it would be a general fund
appropriation
number 41.
you're looking for what this one that
one yeah
um
yeah right here point eight point okay
so we'll hear from um
them I think next week as far as a
Department of Business and economic
Affairs I don't have the list in front
of me Melissa and Mike do you have our
schedule for the next are they coming in
next week
I think they're in Wednesday Wednesday
okay this Wednesday
should
I want to just take home and stuff we'll
get on this so like okay
so we're gonna go to oh you got it yeah
yes it is Wednesday
page 18 historic housing preservation
tax credit
that's uh a new section uh
where
the development of residential property
not single family
provides a
tax credit if it meets certain criteria
there is
um
there's a cap on the amount of five
million dollars in any fiscal year
and there's also similar language in a
Senate bill
that's in Senate Finance right now
to me this seems like something
ways a mean should get as a bill
yeah
rather than us
well it's hard to make a judge
right
but this this is a credit so it's not
just a deduction so it could cost us
five million a year here so this is a
big number
yeah we could we could ask them about it
or just say no and let them find a
legislature to put it to put it in next
year right somebody wants this right
I can tell you this is modeled after the
cdfa credit very similar parameters as
cdfa
the requirements are a little bit
different but the way the tax credit is
basically word for word as cdfa tax
credit and what is cefa
Community
um development housing or Community
Development Finance Authority thank you
um
well it's in older buildings
yeah
it's important
as at a minimum right either say no or
ask them
okay
like Mike Hoffman said there's a similar
bill being heard in this in Senate
Finance right now with very similar
languages so there's been a lot of talk
and discussion on there too if you
wanted some more information we could
get you the committee report on that so
you could have a read through of what
was discussed on that if you'd like
have they made a determination or no
they're still talking um I think maybe
tomorrow we'll come up to vote on it
okay with some amendments I think
who's the Prime sponsor that
uh Senator Innis
does it have a fiscal note
it does
10 million
um it's broken out because there's other
Appropriations involved in it but it's
it's less because it's 65 percent of the
five five million dollars so the
donation or the credit that's being made
is 65 of 5 million of the cap and then
that can be carried forward so I think
the first year is that that 65 of the 5
million and after that it's
indeterminable because there can be a
carry forward of that credit if not used
against the BET BBT or insurance premium
tax credit
hmm
OS
I was going off the top of my head
is it 231
foreign
oh it's not that the person getting the
credit has themselves
um restored house
restored a historic thing it's that
they've contributed
they made a donation
to this Housing Authority historic
something right
I guess
okay so let's let's
um
get the data from Senator Ennis and ask
ways and means if they think they're
likely to want to pass this bill in the
first fiscal year it's 3.25 million and
then an indeterminable increase in the
Years After
okay so it's at least six up to that yep
if the if the full cap was met
okay so not yet okay
all right next one invest NH program
page 19.
what's the number of the percent of bill
by the way
SB sp31
thank you all right invest in h program
do we hear about this
yeah
this is a program for Workforce housing
um
foreign
okay yeah so this is um there's another
big box item
30.
the 25 is another 25.
yeah so this one is just 30.
all right so I think you probably want
to hold on to this one this again is
also in that same SB 231 that I just
spoke about as well that the Senate's
currently hearing oh I see
okay
all right well
right but this is just a straight
expenditure right
make grants and loans for the purpose of
accelerating
Workforce outing
no I think it's just spending
yeah
foreign
right and
accelerated
this will be within Bea so we could ask
them to speak about this on Wednesday as
well if you'd like
yeah let's do that and and I object in
General on the fact that it doesn't say
the maximum Grant is so much right it's
it lets it it lets the department decide
I think that's a little too broad
but maybe this is one of those things
they've already been doing for 10 years
and some other guys and they're going to
you know just continue it under this
name or something like that right so
okay so which department are we talking
about
back
business and economic Affairs okay in
the coming Wednesday this may be related
to some things they've done with the uh
our money that the state received it
extends extends it using general funds
I'll let you
go right along okay sure so we're on um
there's 30 million for
um
for housing this invest NIH program so
we're going to ask about it on Wednesday
yeah and notice it's 2023
right so this is leftover money from
this year
so this is money that otherwise would go
into the rainy day fund I guess
okay
all right next section is
section four okay so so these are all
three together yeah effective date
for some reason you wrote them as
separate
John is going to the Housing Finance
Authority
so the index uses the section numbers in
the bill
oh I see
so
and
in the last couple of years when
drafting House Bill 2 instead of having
all the effective dates piled up at the
end of the bill which was very confusing
OS has tried to where they can put the
effective dates with the section
I see so you can see when that section
is effective without flipping back and
forth all right so the next thing we're
going to consider is sections 47 and 48.
yes yes so that's another 25. and uh
Ben Frost of the New Hampshire Housing
Finance has has been invited sometime
Friday he'll be here to discuss that
okay it's not scheduled yet she was just
on the phone trying to give oh was he he
sent an email saying he he's available
to come Friday just tell us tell him
when
because there's somewhat of an
overlapping purpose between this 25 and
the previous 30.
interesting to hear why they decided to
do it into two separate manners
and not to be redundant but this is also
in that same Senate bill so they'll have
some in the committee report they'll
have some language on this
does the Senate Bill prevent somebody
from
applying for both sets of funds for the
same development
so we'll get 65 percent here and another
65 percent there and we're happy
[Laughter]
okay
all right Bridges House special account
uh page 30.
I don't think that
that appropriated money I think that was
just a place to
donate yeah richest houses oh Mom no
money right
Mr Hoffman we sure there's no money here
there's no appropriation for that
so we should be okay with that I think I
feel fine about that an empty money
okay
so that's uh 66 and 67.
and now Corrections again so we're going
to wait on these right yeah
okay
so now we're down to page 31 section 75.
oh this is to buy the building for the
Attorney General
yeah we have the Department of Justice
coming in tomorrow at 9 30. okay
Gucci
wait where are you
page 31 right section 75 yeah
so the
question there I mean that involves Das
too because are we leasing that place
are we buying it
this was one
uh Melissa Mr Hoffman did you get a hold
of someone from Das to come as well
tomorrow to discuss this yes thanks
I mean it's all involved with everything
that's going on with the parking garage
so that's good if they come in
question Mr Hoffman or Melissa how do we
find out what arpa funds we can use
and not for items like this
seems very fluid
commissioner Caswell will be here and
he's also the
the person in charge of the Gopher
organization
that administered the federal funds
so that would be a good question for
them and there's also
some spending information on their
website
um we have a she where we track what's
come in through fiscal but as far as
allowable uses he would probably be one
of the better people to ask
you'll be here Wednesday at three
you might warn them we're going to ask
him I mean I I'd like to understand the
procedure too
we're getting them
carry on sir
okay next is the parking garage and
here's that's that's
um section 79 toward the bottom of page
31.
and and unfortunately our house bill has
25 million not 15 and I was I asked dais
and they said 25 is correct so therefore
this 15 needs to be increased to 25.
no
either way because the bill is going to
come up either next week or the week
after in full committee okay so do you
want to just
Mr Hoffman Melissa we can just remove
this since we've got a separate house
bill is that correct
you could you could remove it
um
add the house bill language to the
trailer Bill if you want it all in one
place it's whatever you decide
representative McGuire since you were in
the minority on that and you have a
preference I want to be fair
well yeah I mean I think the what makes
sense is to edit this paragraph to have
the 25 and if there's any other language
from the house bill
there's a lot in the house bill was this
I thought it was sort of a short well no
well I mean I'm
the oversight the committee language
well this would be the proper place for
it I think well if it passes it will go
to the floor and go to the Senate
because it's kind of a rush to get going
yeah
oh because this is 2023 yeah you'd
rather just pass it as a bill yeah since
it came out as a bill I know that's a
preference of the speaker okay
and then
um and just on our list
mentally subtract 25 million from 2023.
yeah Melissa and Mr Hoffman will make a
note that with the house bill
recommendation okay that's fine yeah so
let's remove 79 and 80.
you have confidence in its passage I
seem to be the only I was the only one
who testified against the the all the
various you know so but you keep us on
our toes
yeah
so we'll we'll make a note to delete it
guys
thanks
okay
all right representative where where are
we going next
okay natural and cultural resources
Krista McAuliffe Memorial on the next
page
and they'll be here at one o'clock on
Wednesday it's not something we may want
to bring up
unless we're happy with Statehouse
grounds
please
I would have asked if when they're here
if 500 000 is what they think would
build it words just to get it going or
what looks like it's all encompassing
anyway
all right Melissa and Mr Highfield just
a note in case we forget when they come
in on Wednesday to ask about a close
Center or the memorial
um
Wednesday all right then there's on page
uh section 97
again the Department of Natural and
cultural resources State Library million
dollars
so they'll be in to see us again
Wednesday
so we could do that Wednesday okay
well they talked about this didn't they
okay same page Board of tax and land
Appeals
um
is an attorney
line
um 17.
all it all it's doing is adding one
sentence that one member of the board of
tax and land appeals shall be an
attorney
I mean I'm looking at their budget
separately
yeah see we had them in here on the 16th
for their budget presentation
I think we're okay with their
budget at the time yeah
did did that budget anticipate this
change that's in HP hb2 I think actually
one of the Commissioners is a lawyer
isn't that correct Mr Hoffman yes it
doesn't add a new position it just says
one of the members shall be an attorney
they did have a request to make an
adjustment for their doat costs and we
have that on a sheet of additional
requests
so are you okay with them
requiring the attorney because again I
think at least one of them is an
attorney already I believe so yes yeah
yeah I was inclined in general to give
them what
the resources they want because they
seem quite efficient and heavily used
right so we're considering raising their
65 fee to I don't know a hundred dollars
or something else yeah I'm fine with it
yeah okay
all right next one repeal the
communication Services tax
Ways and Means took that out didn't they
um that's true yes in there well
I'm not sure if it's
they listed it right but on the other
hand
they just went by existing law right so
it's I don't I'm not sure that they
really make a decision to keep it or did
they
um
yeah just give us 17. I think house
resolution 17 gives us you know if we
don't change any laws here's what you're
going to make you know so
so the pleasure of our group
yeah they have it here
um I'm not excited about repealing it
when I look at all the other how much
money was that it's 30 million 30
million
it's a lot of dough it just leave that
alone for the time being yeah
um someone made a com comment to me that
if there are no tax cuts we lose 100
Republican votes
that wasn't me and uh so if that's true
this is the the smallest possible tax
cut there is right so
[Laughter]
so I don't know I
think this is a matter for the whole
committee and something else right it's
yeah it's a substantial it's a
substantial amount it's 56 million for
the for the biennials and there's a lot
more to it than fixing a telephone
so we'll put that on hold as far as
bring it up before the full committee
yeah
that makes sense
or when we get closer to the wire
department of revenue is coming in on
Wednesday at 10 so these Department of
Revenue things are quite a few of them
here we can
these two way down through 108 109.
so
those enhanced 9-1-1 is that Revenue so
that's that takes care of sections 101
through 110 yes so
just changing the statute story
references or fixing them yes
well like some of them I see they've
deleted a reference to the communication
Services test so it would depend so it's
related yeah some of it I mean I'm
looking at 10 section 106
107 is public utilities
yeah
related changes
so that reminds me of Representative
McGuire
I had fiscal that Friday that you
handled
uh
the department of energy and the
Community Development Finance Authority
did you guys find those okay that was on
the 17th of February
any recollection Melissa or Mike on the
17th when the department of energy and
the three attached boards and
yeah we just sort of
any need for them to come back or
um
yeah I don't think so unless
I don't think we've decided to have them
come back but we didn't dream of making
a decision without him oh yeah that's
why I lead representative there's one
related bill which is House Bill 234
right and so
um
representative McWilliams bill yeah
renewable energy credits
and that came out without recommendation
I think you're right yeah so
a lot of this like the 911 I'm looking
at this redefining communication
services
so it's related to the tax repeal I
don't know
yes all the way through Section 110 has
to do with that Communications tax yeah
we can ask the commissioner when she's
here on Wednesday to maybe go over some
of this it's pretty confident right
I do believe Ways and Means has a bill
right to repeal this tax okay and I
don't know if they've acted on It or Not
by the energy here
anything on that Mike a Melissa that
weighs the means a bill to repeal
I'm not aware of that but we can follow
up we'll I'll check with uh
Chris too on what the resolution does
because sometimes they show current law
and then they have other adjustments
all right
all right page 39 labor
so we have one that 110
which is emergency waiver out-of-state
business employees Communications sir
okay
that's where it talks about
communication services
you're correct for house ways and means
they do have a repeal CST bill it goes
to Executive session on March 8th so in
a couple of days okay thanks Melissa and
all right so we should wait for that
also on our tracking sheet we don't have
any additional requests for the
Department of energy
okay
so are we good with the Department of
energy checking them off so the LBA has
another check mark
anybody
yes I guess
representative
well he just made a reference of the
Department of energy that was here back
on February uh
17.
you remember the day we saw Department
of energy puc and
we're not talking about that we're just
talking about the regular budget
the big budget
those particular sections
representative Leachman wants to know
can we sort of pass those or or do we
want to revisit I mean I just don't
remember them well enough I don't
remember thinking I had a problem but
we should at least take a glance we'll
we'll hold off then
all right so I think now we jump to what
a back to house bill 2. I want to oh go
ahead I do seem to recall there was one
guy who said he was new and he hadn't
had any work yet or something right he
was he was given some tasks and like
nobody had applied for that thing
whatever it was
do you remember that guy no that was the
uh site evaluation committee oh that's
right yeah and uh you had asked him for
uh the cost of the permits for something
at uh Seabrook
and I have a voicemail
from him that I haven't deciphered yet
um
because he was talking about 1991
dollars converted to current dollars so
I don't know how relevant it is I gotta
listen to it again
but in general he seemed very underused
right I mean he
right
he he he fielded these requests and
there was hardly any of them right so
the uh the structure is there for when a
utility wants to build something yeah
but there's not there are times when
there's not a lot of activity right he
said there was nothing pending right
right exactly but in those site yeah
applications that's where Northern Pass
was right so they had plenty to do for a
while
all right
his little section yeah yeah yeah he had
somebody that was the
control I guess
but it well anyways it was an idea for
if you absolutely needed to cut
something there might be some room there
okay well wait Mike and see what you can
decipher and get that back to represent
my choir yep thanks
so we have button 112 labor 111.
so 111 through 118 all have to do with
the Department of Labor some of those
are changes in response to an LBA audit
had to do with where they deposit the
fees they collect
so a lot of it is clean up but the
Department of Labor will be in here
Wednesday I believe
the other department of labor yet
tomorrow
at 11 A.M okay
yeah instead of putting things in
general funds they're putting it in some
sort of restricted fund it looks like
so we'll ask labor about those tomorrow
so
penalty appeals or
workman's compensation 150.
so they they can talk to us about the
Family and Medical Leave Insurance labor
I would think so 116.
yes okay
so this one the attorney received
400 per diem
don't they get the 400 per hour
okay check with the guy on the end there
yeah
see the attorney member of the board
shall receive 413.
page 40. yeah
line 13. all right
that sounds like a bargain right
[Laughter]
so
the other members
compliance
all right so we're gonna ask these guys
tomorrow yeah tomorrow yeah so that'd be
tomorrow but again they'll be here at
11.
okay family medical leave 116. that
should be with them as well
but then going to 117 boiler and
pressure vessel exception I mean
118 is quite large so
I know I'm sorry so then we skip all the
way to 131 I believe abandoned property
yeah there's some weird stuff that's
part of I guess labor which is this
boiler inspections I think maybe
elevator inspections are also in labor
right if you go into an elevator and
look at who signs it's like the
commissioner of Labor right so he goes
and inspects us well somebody works here
but my point is there's a few things
like that that are just kind of randomly
scattered around anyway
okay so I think we jump all the way to
131 my
highlight is correct
so unclaimed and abandoned property that
was with the treasury
you have any issues with that
so we can check that off Mr Hoffman
Melissa
now revenue is sharing we always suspend
this and he thought about that
Mike remind us what is it like 25
million a years or something like that
and I think it's been since 2010 2011
that it's been suspended
it's been out yeah ever since uh yeah
about 2000 during the big crash I think
I think so yeah
give you a big explanation oh yeah
representative evil wants to add it back
in no suspension and
Jerry wants to give a little more to
want Vernon
oh Tony needs some more too
[Laughter]
so thought so we want to wait on that or
it's again it's it's weird that it's
here because we always suspend but
well I guess you have to do it by
Statute right right to do it I mean by
the way if we don't suspend it we do it
right I mean or repeal it
from the Surplus
you and I agree
this gentleman we shouldn't be too
absolute here but this gentleman I have
always agreed the rainy day final the
big Surplus all that money is really
taxpayers money it really should go back
we've always agreed on that one pretzel
one thing
but okay so we can sit on it we can
think about it
could you Mike and Melissa get us the
actual the hard numbers because I
remember it's like about 25 million a
year but see what it works out to as far
as this bike you know because it goes
there's an escalator built into it this
isn't rooms of meals or is it no it's
something separating for me it's just a
payment from the general fund direct to
the yeah but there's a formula buy a
formula yeah okay
that's a little different
yeah depending how much is in there as
we know yeah
that would be at least a 50 million
dollar hit I think around
this isn't that funny is another 25
million years
everything you know
well and if you did want to share it
wouldn't have to be 25 even it's worth
hanging on
[Laughter]
so like one
133 electric utility restructuring
what's uh Mr Hoffman Melissa
I believe that's just some remaining
cleanup from when they created the
department of energy two years ago yes I
look at it that's what it looked like to
me except they
added offshore wind
because it
no it's um offshore wind is line 9 and
10 page 40.
I would be fine
133 134 135
136 and 137.
I would imagine there was a problem we
would have heard from chairman Vos yeah
what do you guys think about one third
oh wait so 130 132 to 137 is okay
here London
previous of the commissioner
Department of energy
it's a good question
that's what it has been though right
that language yeah that's not a chance
it's not new
but this is the fun representative
McWilliams wants more money in
I think
I believe you're correct
yep but I think it looks like they're
just adding a reference to Offshore wind
here too yeah
what is this
so
133 to 137. well let's see
damn
so we're just working on some budget
stuff but just to give you an idea what
we'll be looking for any of your hb2
impacts I noticed like boxing they want
to move out of your neck of the woods
and some other things just to give you a
little repair
heads up
so so are we agreed on 133 to 137 I
believe so all right everybody okay with
that
now 138 though yeah I looked at that
sort of open in
well it does require both the fiscal
committee
and governor and Council
so that's
amazing
it means they want to treat the
department of energy like the judicial
Council ah very good right so that they
run out of money
they're absolutely necessary therefore
they can come ask for more
that's what it is
yeah Deanna and I have had a
representative McGuire an event this
conversation before I think the fiscal
committee has way too much power even
though I've been there a long time
but it's true it basically usurps the
legislature do a lot of things when the
legislature's not in session we do a lot
of things so the original intent was was
laudable yeah because without it
but the state wouldn't spend any money
after the legislative
but so a number of different state
agencies as you know come to fiscal
whether it's Corrections or judicial
Council and we can or cannot approve
like traditional I mean Chris I think I
don't like this okay personally I just
think it's
in general when people come to the
fiscal committee they want to move money
right they have it over here but they
need it over there so they shift because
this is saying funds we'll pour more in
yeah right
that's almost a billion and a quarter
last year yeah it's a lot of money
so the way I explain fiscal to people is
the budget is a point in time
right the budget is our best guess for
what's going to happen over the next two
years
and the fiscal committee is the
in-course correction
right things didn't go quite the way you
expected so the fiscal committee can
make changes so that you get to where
you want to go right so that that's the
idea
um because we can't always predict
perfectly
what revenues coming in what you know
grants are going to come in all that
sort of stuff so you have to have
somebody who along the way can make a
change
yes yes
dispensation by stats
because they don't have the authority
now certainly Corrections has it
judicial Council has it so is this a
standard Department of Health and Human
Services has it yeah so you're we'd be
giving another agency within state
government they could I don't want to I
shouldn't say this but it's kind of true
if you're a little sloppy with your
budget then you come and get it fixed or
is it it could be a problem you know
there could be a problem like over time
with corrections is a huge problem they
never have enough money
so thoughts on 138 Representatives
are they coming back no no not energy
unless you want them to come back Mr
chair
just one difference here
um
judicial Council comes in for General
funds this is a utility assessment right
and the department and the puc are
funded by those kinds of assessments
yeah that's a good point
thoughts
well since it's two o'clock we'll stop
at 1 38. Melissa Mr Hoffman and come
back to that
at a later date
so it being
two o'clock
we have the Department of State I also
have the boxing and wrestling
and I also had a note here the Ombudsman
they fall under your jurisdiction right
so maybe you can talk about that
position how it's working out but
so Mr secretary and Deputy are good to
see you and
yeah we you might you might as well come
up you make all the decisions so you
might as well come up yeah yeah
but thanks for the record if you could
just identify yourselves thank you Mr
chairman members of the committee I'm
David Scanlon uh Secretary of State
I'm Aaron Hennessey deputy secretary of
state
um
just before we get into the hb2 items uh
I'll say generally that
the proposed budget for our department
is an efficiency budget so we you know
complied with the governor's request and
submitted that budget
we have created four new positions in
this budget
and there's one conversion from a
full-time temporary to a to a classified
position
uh the reason for the positions
primarily are because of all the work
that we've been doing with our I.T
systems
uh updating our website uh getting our
databases in good order and functioning
properly and we've made a lot of Headway
uh in those areas and obviously we want
to maintain that so uh hopefully you've
been on our website and seen some of
that activity but there have been some
major improvements there
in terms of
uh there is one small request that I
would like to make in the budget the
Canadian trade Council met this morning
in an organizational meeting and that
Council has had
a budget line in our in our budget of
eight thousand dollars per year that
hasn't been changed probably at least
the last decade even though the council
has become a lot more active and so I'd
like to request uh changing that eight
thousand dollars to ten thousand dollars
trying not to break the bank
uh let's see what we don't have the same
Pages yeah probably don't have the same
Pages here is that all travel
some of it is travel some of it is to
attend events between the United States
and Canada for example last year the
Canadian trade Council hosted
a contention from
a contingent from Quebec to come down to
Manchester and tour the armi facility
there Dean cayman's
facility and it was a it was a really
really good event but those funds helped
sponsor things like that as well as
allowing
as well as allowing members to attend
meetings like CSG because they have a
United States Canadian function there as
well
it actually looks like if I mean it
actually looks like you only spent 35
3600 this year or last year
so it doesn't look like you're coming
close we check coming over here it looks
like there's just over 6 000 in the
budget
um for for the biennium uh and that
money I expect will be spent before the
end of this fiscal year
the
uh
yes
so the the Canadian trade Council put on
um historically we've done different
things crossing the border back and
forth and taking turns and this year was
New Hampshire's turn and they had an
event in the fall which spent the week
they had to save up their funds from
last year to spend at the event this
year
yeah
yes
and then a couple things I'm going to
let Aaron jump in here as well but just
a couple of things with hb2 that that I
noticed
on page 110
it talks about the uh the board of
Auctioneers
moving over to oplc
on line 13 on that page
uh it says the board with the approval
of the Secretary of State shall adopt
rules pursuant to RSA 541a and so I
would suggest that if they're moving to
oplc that they just take us out of it
and then
uh generally speaking
there are a number of boards uh
commissions and licenses that are being
removed from the Secretary of State's
office in house bill 2.
20 years ago the Secretary of State's
office was the repository for those
types of entities in fact that the board
of licensure and certification was
administratively attached to the
Secretary of State's office and in the
interim a new agency has been created
where most of those boards and
commissions have been moved to
um there were some stragglers left in
the Secretary of State's office
for example
Bill bondsman
regulated by our division of Securities
um
there's only one of those maybe two that
are actually licensed
um you know picture uh a bounty hunter I
mean that's basically what it is
um
uh so there aren't there you know
there's
just one or two licensed individuals in
New Hampshire for that purpose
um
another example is uh
uh athletic agents
I don't know if there's any that are
currently registered in New Hampshire if
there are there's only one or two
we have Hawkers and Peddlers licenses
which does not generate a lot of Revenue
and uh
and so things like that so everything
that is being proposed to be moved out
of the Department of State we really
don't have an objection to
Aaron do you want anything
um the the Hawkers and Peddlers and the
sports agents both of those are
scheduled in House Bill too just to be
simply eliminated not just moved out so
yeah
and again we would not object to that
do you have Mr secretary do you have a
list of those agencies that you could
give to Mr Hoffman and Melissa just so
him when they're all on the same page
with you have like you said no problem
with any of those being reassigned or
abolished right and I'll get that too Mr
Hoffman thanks
I'll I'll yield to it or
uh so one thing I would like to add is
that the house and the Senate are very
busy this year
um especially with election laws but
some some related to our department
having to do with Health and Human
Services or uh the Commerce Committee
and
um I don't know that any of the bills
that are making their way through the
process right now actually have
Appropriations with them so that's one
thing that I would like to bring to your
attention
um the Senate has already passed a few
that do not have Appropriations
um they're bipartisan supported bills so
I'm thinking that especially since the
house has some
similar almost exact bills that seem to
have a lot of support that their will
that you will be getting house bills
sooner than the Senate ones but I just
wanted to bring to your attention
um there's a a an election portal that
is going to be that the Senate has
passed already and the cost of that is
between
um about 500 000 in the first year and
then ongoing between two and three
hundred thousand dollars annually after
that
um there is
um a vital records related bill that the
Senate um floor will be hearing um
Thursday it passed out a committee and
the net effect of that would be
approximately three hundred thousand
dollars in the first year and two
hundred thousand dollars in Lost revenue
revenue going forward for a vital
records division
um and then just some smaller ones where
the incremental cost when looking at it
individually as a bill is not much safe
35 to 55 000 a year or maybe a little
bit of extra time for our elections
division
um but that when you put all of them
together we might need somebody else to
help support that going forward so
something to bring to your attention I
know the LBA does a good job of tracking
all the bills that have passed out of
the different houses and um
but I'm happy to bring those to your
attention as time goes on because I know
we're a little bit early in your process
so are these bills with fiscal notes
that we haven't seen because I don't
remember any of these on our list
they weren't early bills I guess yeah
there have been quite a few in the
Senate side but we haven't had a lot
here
the house election law committee has
still is holding several of them I don't
I'm not sure what your cutoff date is I
know
yeah so for bills to come to us as a
second committee already gone so
yes that's a good point and there's also
thank you for pointing that out and
that's one other thing I wanted to bring
up is that there is a bill that house
election law is undertaking right now
that did not come to us for a fiscal
note which would have shouldn't have
come to us for a fiscal note so um if
that does pass I will bring that to your
attention and go to the LBA to have a
fiscal note added cool
so moving right along anything else you
wait for it
yeah the the only other thing is that
every four years we have a presidential
primary and the uh the budget currently
supports that expense
which will be in the next fiscal year
and
you know the only problem we'll have is
as Aaron said you know some of these
legislative specials passed uh pass it
will uh
be difficult to meet the costs if there
isn't an additional appropriation that
goes along with it
now could you give us a little
background on the Hava funds and there's
been a lot of stuff out there about the
need for new voting machines the cost of
same and where the money's coming from
for the new voting machines
is really two separate topics there the
voting machines and then the Java funds
the help America vote Act was passed in
and shortly after that New Hampshire
received about 17 million dollars
in Hava funds
the um there was a federal mandate that
all states had to create a Statewide
centralized voter database with those
funds they had to place accessible
voting equipment in each polling place
for individuals with disabilities
uh they had to conduct extensive poll
worker training
the funds could also be used for voter
education and
enforcement activity by the State
Attorney General's office on the Java
laws
there were two types of funds that came
through in the initial uh
payments
one was called Title One funds which
could be used
for the general Improvement of Elections
provided it was for a new program and
not sustaining something that was
already existing
and then the the
majority of the funds the title II funds
were for actually meeting the mandates
of the help America vote act that could
not be spent on anything else other than
let's say wide voter database
accessible equipment poll worker
training and so over uh at the time the
legislature decided to create what we
call the election fund
to house the Hava money
and put a requirement at the time that
we could spend one twentieth
of those funds in any given year with
the id idea being that we would hold the
principal amount
as long into the future as we could
surviving off the interest
and uh and uh you know funding the
programs that way
and so here we are 20 years later
there's still 12.8 million dollars in
the election fund
and we've been able to continue those
those programs we're on probably the
Third
generation of accessible voting
equipment in the polling places we're
real rebuilding actually replacing the
Legacy Legacy voter database that we
have which will be completed sometime
this summer
uh
the
funds annually are being spent on uh
maintaining the Statewide voter database
and a really extensive well done poll
worker education program
um I should say that in the interim when
they initially passed we could spend one
twentieth we're now down to 112. so um
and and that translates into about a
million dollars per year
more recently in 2018
we received roughly three million
dollars in additional Haba funds to be
used for
cyber security primarily
um at the time that was the crisis of
the day and so you know our our system
is pretty well protected that way
because we have used the money for
security measures uh in our information
technology systems related to elections
and then of course
the elections in 2020 we had the
pandemic uh
in full loan scale and we received
another 3.3 million dollars in Harbor
funds
to be spent just to address the pandemic
issues
that entire amount with the exception of
about three hundred thousand dollars was
sent directly to the cities and towns to
reimburse them for the additional costs
of conducting an election and we did
that on the basis of the number of
absentee ballots that each Town sent out
because there was a dramatic increase at
the time in the number of absentee
ballots that were requested
and voted on and then the remaining
roughly three hundred thousand dollars
we spent on a CPA firm to handle the
record keeping that was required to meet
the federal audit of those hovel funds
that were that were spent on the
pandemic
um
so that money was gone we are currently
in line to receive another one million
dollars
in Hava security funds three percent of
which have to be spent on security and
then and then the balance we could spend
on you know meeting the
the requirements of the help America
vote Act
um
which will bring our balance up uh
closer to 14 million dollars
then we have the issue of the electronic
ballot counting devices the voting
machines that are used in polling places
those the machines are currently used
are reaching the end of their uh
functional life although I believe we
could squeeze a couple more elections
out of them if we add to
but at the same time the Bell luck
commission is working with us
in a very aggressive way to get ready to
approve the you know the next generation
of ballot counting devices
uh in fact in the upcoming town meeting
elections next week
we're going to be testing three
different manufacturers devices in four
towns in New Hampshire
Londonderry and Milford will be depended
we'll be testing a device manufactured
by Dominion
uh Winchester will be testing a device
made by es and S and Ashland will be
testing a device made by clear ballot
we're going to have members of our staff
and the attorney general staff
monitoring that over the course of the
election and then in the days following
the election there's going to be an
audit of each of those devices at the
polling places where they were used
so that we can confirm the accuracy of
the results of those machines
the um technology is much newer than
than the current accumo machine which is
an optical scan technology
it's simply that technology simply uses
light to measure marks on the ballot and
and Records votes based on where those
marks are made
the newer technology is digital scan
technology so an image of every single
ballot front and back can be recorded by
those devices and used for auditing
purposes
um
generally the legislature passed in the
last couple of sessions audit programs
one of which is a high using a high
speed scanner to
to count the ballots using the digital
technology it is pretty impressive in in
what that can do and certainly verified
the accuracy of the results of the
current accuvote machines that we're
using in the polling places
it is up to the individual towns to
decide whether or not they're going to
use a ballot counting machine in their
polling place
and it is the responsibility of the
towns to pay for the elections that take
place at the local level whether it's a
local election or a state election
the towns that have decided to use
battle accounting devices are saving
money by using that instead of having to
hire teams to come in and count the
ballots at the end of the night
excuse me so
um you know we believe that that is a
cost that is the responsibility of the
Town replacing those machines I know
that there are many towns that have a uh
you know a fund where they're saving
money for the future purchase of a new
accounting device
there have been proposals before the
legislature for several sessions now
excuse me
to use the hobby funds to spend the
hobby monies down
for the purchase of equipment among
other things
um
we believe that the program that we have
been maintaining using the the interest
balance of those funds
uh has been very efficient and very
effective and as long as we keep that
balance healthy it will be
a long time before we have to go to the
New Hampshire taxpayers and say we have
to fund these programs now through the
general fund
um
and that's the danger of spending the
fund balance down on special projects
foreign
we are receiving additional Java funds
that are taking us above and beyond the
12 times and so we are open to a
one-time program where we may be able to
help with the cost of uh things like new
ballot counting devices but when we do
that we want to do it in a uniform way
that treats every town and City fairly
and helps them you know improve the
conduct of Elections generally in New
Hampshire
so that's where we're at with that Mr
chair hopefully that answered your
question
it did thank you very much other
questions represent McGuire
I think way yeah anyways
um are there multiple models of each
machine so if a town is a Tiny Town they
get a cheaper machine than a for their
Manchester they need a
higher capacity machine
that's going to be a negotiation that we
have to have with the companies that
manufacture the machines the trend over
time has been that these companies
have developed ballot counting machines
but they also want to sell a suite of
package you know a suite of other
services for example uh
you know a ballot creation software so
that you know you create your own ballot
but it can only be used with their
ballot accounting device
um
way too expensive for you know many
towns in New Hampshire so what we're
looking for primarily is just a
standalone battle accounting device we
did test a device in the general
election that used open source software
the software worked great but the
hardware that was used for that device
was very lacking and so they're trying
to make improvements to be under
consideration New Hampshire is a small
market for these devices so it's not
going to make sense for New Hampshire to
decide to use more than two
companies ideally it would be one like
we have now so
um you know we are concerned about the
economies of scale and making them
affordable and functional and and that's
part of the equation
as the number of absentee ballots gone
back to pre-pandemic levels or yes yes
okay good let's talk about your budget
um
other funds is is the biggest section is
that business license fees or something
is that um
page 152.
which um which department are you in the
whole department the state this is the
grand total kind of thing
at the top of page 152 it says other
funds 8 million
out of your total of 11 and a half say
Facebook
okay
so Paula has informed me that those are
funds that are charged in corporations
and securities that go to the general
fund
they lapse I guess they lapse the
general fund right
yeah
so those are fees on
corporations right of some kind yeah
they would be they would be charges I
suppose you could call them fees for
certain registrations
gotcha okay
um and so your general fund usage you
actually use two million but you want to
bump that up to three
so that seems like a significant
increase yeah
looking at that so fiscal year 2022
actual General funds 2 million seventy
three thousand we definitely don't have
that sorry okay let me find it
so this is
but on the other hand I guess you had a
lot of federal funds in 2022 which
you're expecting to go down
this is the adjusted occupants
which can you tell me what number we
have for 2023
2.6 yeah we have 2.6 correct right so
the actual for 2022 is much less right
so you must have elapsed
quite a bit or something like that
like we can find out what the what the
difference was for that I I do want to
point out that a lot of the general fund
line right there
there's a lot of increase in rent that
has occurred over the years from
Department of admin Securities and we
can't control that number on what they
charge us
um we we have
three different locations of where we're
located one in the State House second
floor and then third floor in the
um Annex of the State House corporations
and securities is over there and then we
have the archives building where
archives vital records and hover are
located we get charged rent for all of
those
it's been a significant increase I don't
know if other departments have mentioned
that previously no so yeah maybe you
could point out the line or the page
earlier the b28 line item 28. okay class
28. yeah okay
all right but I can I will find out for
you what the what the difference was for
22 to 23.
and you got a considerable federal funds
in 2022 1.6 million
and you're expecting more like 1.2
going forward
that
so the 2020
22 would have been
um
some homophones yeah well I'm thinking
Hava funds
and then you know the additional funds
coming in would be the one million
dollars plus it requires a 20 match so
that would be 1.2
would you like a breakdown of the 1.6
that we had in 22 Yeah and how it
compares to what you expect going
forward yeah my my guess is that would
be the variance in the Java funds from
year to year and tell us about the six
added employees
uh
we have uh
been making some changes within the
department uh generally
focused primarily on the information
technology services
um we are putting a business analyst in
each of our divisions so that that
person can understand uh what the
business needs are of the office and the
customers and then be able to translate
those needs uh into the way the software
programs are developed so that we're
working efficiently and we're on top of
contracts and and all of those items
the the Staffing really is is
pretty much one position in each of the
major divisions
so it's not a it's not a dramatic
increase but they are serving really
important functions uh we are also going
through uh a transition of employees
primarily because of retirement we've
had a lot of long time employees now
that are starting to leave a tremendous
amount of knowledge going with them and
it's tough to find one person that can
you know do the job of the individual
that was there before although we are
acquiring some very competent new staff
um and we're having the same issues uh
that other departments are in terms of a
labor shortage and trying to keep it
full Staffing
do you have a lot of open positions
uh we have open positions in pollinating
do you have a number we have eight
gotcha okay so about 10 percent
yep yeah okay thanks
further questions from members of The
Division I got one thing representative
Hewitt
um
one of the things I think that was or is
in your department have the the bail
bondsman as opposed to Baylor
commissioners uh
have you folks had any contact from the
justice department or anybody concerning
that because the there is a there is a
there's legislation being prepared
to completely overhaul the uh the system
of bail and in criminal cases and
I don't know where that's going to go
but how much activity do you have I I
remember a bill commissioner in
Manchester uh had an office right over
where one of the judges had an office
um but is there much activity in the
bail bond bail bondsman act uh
no it has been declining over the years
and you know 20 years ago there might
have been eight uh but today there's
only one or two yeah okay
Mr chair I think that you had wanted to
hear about the new position that is
administratively attached to our
department the ombudsman
thanks Aaron
we we have the ombudsman
it's a significant line on your budget I
think it was like 128 000 a year or
something that caught my eye so you do
have the position filled and
the position is filled it was an
appointment by the governor the office
is
just administratively attached to us so
we're providing the office space and uh
in the office equipment but the the
right to know Ombudsman is
responsible for their own budget and
determining what the needs are and you
know convincing the governor's office if
that's what they need
Tom Kerr is the Zion budsman who
prior to this position was an employee
at admin services
did lots of work with the right to know
area
all right I did have a a budget question
um
kind of a little follow-up on to
representative McGuire's questioning
so your actual expenses on page 152 or
like 14.3 million
and yet in 23 the authorized was 11. I
was just curious how and uh 22 you were
able to cover that additional three I
was looking through the budget and saw
that there was some large expenses for
elections I know we had a presidential
election is that where some of that
increase
is from and you covered it with I'm
assuming
federal funds or
you see the page I'm on air and it's um
so your actual expenses were 14 3 for 22
and
authorized for 23 or
11.4 so it's kind of a curious in the
variance there
the difference we spent 14.3 and 22 and
then had authorized 11.4
yeah I'm going to turn to Paul again
another explanation for that yeah
um some of the expenses we have to
budget them until we're sure that you
know we had space on the revenue we take
in okay so once we receive the revenue
um we're then able to appropriate it and
um and that's why we see it that way
okay thanks
um one area that went up considerably is
vital records
had a big expenditure in 22.
there is a a large I.T project that
they're undertaking
um
and so there is a significant cost cost
involved with that and that made me most
of it 2.4
yeah
they have a vital records Improvement
fund that they used
all is most if not all where that money
comes from
um is it okay if I just get back to
representative McGuire's earlier
question
um so the Ombudsman that is attached to
our office again that we don't that the
governor appoints
um that gen that is the source of
General funds that we didn't used to
have in our office so that's 128 and 24
and 136 and 25 so that would be where a
big general fund increase would have
come from
now it's this individual's office on the
second floor or somewhere else in your
the ombudsman's office is on the third
floor over the ens for the time being
they're getting ready to do a renovation
project there so they're going to be
asking
certain agencies to move around
other questions for the secretary or the
deputy secretary
for those who don't know Aaron was on
finance with us and then abandoned us
went to this went to the Senate and then
abandoned the Senate and that's good to
see where you are good to see you too
your loss is our gained yes it certainly
is it certainly is
so any further questions
seeing none I guess it's just a few
little things you'll get back to us
especially impacts of the House Bill 2
changes we didn't hear about boxing they
don't want boxing anymore
[Laughter]
unless you is there something you can
ask Paul's gonna I think Paul is
prepared to talk about boxing and
wrestling all right
products
you do
uh good afternoon
um I'm Paula Penny from the Secretary of
State's office I'm here on behalf of
commissioner Bobby Stevens who's the
chair of the boxing wrestling commission
he's unable to join us today
um
but boxing and wrestling currently is
attached to the Secretary of State's
office we provide them with the
administrative support that they need as
you can see they have a fairly small
budget
mostly
um with um Personnel money which they
get the Commissioners get a per diem for
each event boxing and wrestling and also
now mixed martial arts which is part of
their purview
um and some travel which is basically
but for mileage between the events
um and as you know it's a little they're
looking to be moved from us to to the
oplc
and um
we're fine with that
questions
Cena I do have one how many events do
they oversee in the course of a year do
you know or you um typically like two or
three a month all that many yeah mostly
smaller I mean not that you would see
advertised per se they have a couple of
big events a year they have a big WWE
event at the
I guess it's this new Arena now and
natural trying to think what it's called
um in Manchester and another big boxing
event but the rest are mostly smaller
boxing events
um some held in Hampton
um Londonderry they have some facilities
for that and they have a couple a month
okay well thanks any
not seeing any further questions thanks
very much you're welcome
seems kind of weird the general funds
are there right not uh other funds yeah
right all right well thanks
I mean it's not big money it's
okay
we all said with the Secretary of
State's office we could check them out
of hospitals yes
okay once
again so I'm not sure Corrections
all right
so what do you think good choice instead
of Science and Technology
thank you